my son will sit in front in front of a
new game he will just click everything
and everything and explore
and discover and understand what what's
being done for an older adult
there's the fear of pressing a button
they don't understand that anything that
they press
find to go back it's a fear of exploring
and therefore
they will not explore right so if it's
not out there and it doesn't explain
exactly what it does
it's not going to be pressed welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
and is sponsored by leumitech hippo
insurance touring upwards labs and
hillel at stanford we all know there's a
huge gap in the ability for elderly to
leverage the use of technology that we
use in our daily life
meet ayton levy the co-founder and ceo
of zeppi
after a two year relocation to canada
ayton learned how hard it is to keep in
touch and care for loved ones especially
when they have difficulties operating
smartphones and tablets
that's why he developed zepi a video
called device that floats
it is the only zero effort tech out
there for older adults and people with
impairments
hey tom levy thank you for joining me
how are you this morning oh i'm i'm very
excited it's a very big day for us
very very good well you're working on it
on a really important cause i'm excited
to hear about
what you're doing there with zeppy but
you have a
background of product management in
quality systems and
and really what i'm truly excited to
hear from you is is your personal
journey but
also in the context of solving such a
meaningful problem for elderly care
so tell me a little bit about yourself
and how do you find yourself
diving into the industry of helping
elderly connect with their loved ones
um well my wife is a gynecologist and
two and a half years ago she got
accepted to a fellowship in canada
uh so we moved the whole family over
there and i've got three kids at the
time they were
two six and eight and um
my parents are back in israel so i
actually found myself holding an ipad
and chasing the kids around to try and
create the experience for my parents uh
as if they're hanging out together it
was just uh
yeah i could i could see uh how
disappointed my mom was from the
experience and there was also the other
side of
my ability to show up at my parents
place to try and help them out
sometimes in the little things you know
that the light in the microwave
is blinking you can go nuts and trying
to go hey mom hold the phone i can't see
it
to try and yeah uh there are a lot of
movie very funny movies about uh
different use cases like that how people
lose it in 10 seconds
mom
um but also it goes to the bigger things
because sometimes you want to hear like
a conversation with the doctor or you
want to see really what's going on
um i'm lucky that my sister lives very
close by
but still the feeling of remote family
caregiving is something that is just
horrendous and because of my product
management
background i immediately started to do
the market research and to see what's
going on out there
and that's where i discovered that this
is a huge pro
before the covet huge problem of
loneliness and isolation
and family caregivers that are chasing
around uh they're actually called the
sandwich generation they've got their
own careers own kids and they're trying
to help their parents and it's just uh
really really hard and right and i mean
the biggest
problem behind it is that um you know
there's always
some kind of technical difficulty on the
older adult side
right that will cause it to break down
and that's uh
i was just mapping out everything on the
user experience and trying to see if i'm
gonna be able to solve it and uh you
know my daughter got a
she got a hello kitty a helium balloon
for her birthday
it was stuck in my living room for two
months uh
and you know it took like uh 10 days for
it to lose a little bit of the helium
and there's a magical day
where the balloon is exactly at
equilibrium
so i'm sitting in the living room and
suddenly this thing is like floating
in a hypnotizing kind of way in front of
my eyes and like oh wow
if i can put the ipad on that that's
going to be awesome
so that's kind of where right whereas
that became uh
came into play so so zeppy is this you
know hands-free
floating zero touch for for elderly but
etan i want to go back
still to the to the pain point because
i'm i'm feeling that pain point on a
daily basis with my two
aging grandparents it's about you know
it's about the dexterity of
clicking on the apps it's about holding
the
and and assimilating to the technology
but can you give me a little bit of a
broader perspective
as they you know with background and
product management and you're
using research what is the phenomena
that we're
that we're exploring here because i i do
think so that most people in the world
still don't empathize with this big
problem
for the communication differences you're
saying that there's you know all the
time there's technical difficulties but
here we are
you know we have zoom calls almost every
day
all day and very rarely we have
significant technical difficulties so
why does it happen with elders
more so than with with with the younger
generation and
what types of of things contribute to
that gap
in the in the ability to assimilate well
you know the world is split into two
it's split into the people who are
taking
care of someone uh who has a certain
level of impairment you know
it's not really about an older adult you
can't say oh my market is the 75 plus
that whole approach is is passe
it's uh it's about people who are
for various reasons it can be cognitive
it can be physical
it can be even psychological uh
that are basically not able to operate
what is trivial for us
and if you have your grandparents and
you can imagine
trying to train them up and i mean with
this covid
a lot of people have done wonders in
training up a lot of people who did were
not technical
but uh there's still unfriendly a huge
portion of the uh of people
who no matter what are not going to be
able to operate it on their own without
any local assistance and it can be the
smallest thing like
connecting the tablet to the charger
that can be a game over for somebody yes
it can be if you're if you're uh you
know there's a
some cool systems that you can actually
hook up to your tv
but then you need to change the hdmi
source
that said game over not going to work if
if you're holding something in your
hands
uh the need to coordinate and point it
towards yourself
i mean you know the classics examples
are uh my kids asking why are my parents
nose so big okay because they're looking
into the tablet and trying to see what's
going
on or why do they need to see uh my
my dad's a hair and his ears because
he's holding up the speaker like that
because he wants to hear so
it's all these multiple little things
but you know what we also uh
i've had a lot of work in user
experience
and then designing and identifying gaps
i mean we all have the uh
the zoom uh lockdown we're sitting in
front of an
uh device in a specific location we're
having uh conversations for business
it's okay but
uh how many of people are on a daily
basis are like uh having coffee together
over zoom
with their parents it's just not an
experience that works and if i
were able to uh present the person's
face for example in the life size that
requires a 20 inch display
it means that we're right now about
a foot and a half away from the display
but in a normal conversation we're
sitting around a coffee table would be
like three four feet away
that's the normal distance why shouldn't
i have that kind of a conversation why
should i see a life-size display why
should it be at
eye level and exactly on top of the sofa
or
the other side of the uh dining table
where the person would be sitting down
it's a different experience and i want
to go back right before we go into the
into the solution that you're providing
here
i think that we said two things that
really um made me think
one was this idea of a game changer you
know every person
interacts differently with a device you
know some people like the dark theme
better some people
are more productive when there's do not
disturb right i mean there's a lot of
these
these different tools that are provided
for us so that we can enjoy the
technology and assimilate to it better
yet what you're saying here is that
there are these things for elderly
things like connecting connecting the
tablet to the charger or even
swiping right maybe pressing some of the
buttons on the touchpad or pressing the
power button on the side
that could be just physical game
changers because of accessibility issues
and you know in the past three four
years i've seen almost every company
make efforts to become more accessible
for those with some disabilities
whether they're hearing impaired or or
they're or they have poor eyesight
yet i don't see nearly enough
accessibility for elderly
in in our day-to-day apps which and so
it's as if they're just treating this
population as if it doesn't matter it
doesn't exist
yet we have a lot of other you know
populations with disabilities that
they're putting so much effort in and
i've been one i've been asking myself
why is that
why do companies not take not provide
solutions for the elderly do you think
is there an economic reason for this
is it just that people don't still don't
realize that there's this huge gap
well i think that the realization has
been coming into play in the last few
years
uh there's a lot of talk around it and
what you can really see is that many
products that have been uh
that have passed the threshold of the
user experience have actually entered
into the aging uh market
and they're the classic consumer
products a lot of the apple various uh
tablets and a lot of by the way the
smart home displays
a lot of rice activation is uh is
bypassing a lot of the different
challenges
and uh the market is actually a monster
because the baby boomers are right
are uh have already gone into their
pension and now are getting to the later
ages
and the baby boomers uh over the years
have never taken anything uh
for granted they they change the market
as they go
um do you know that the actual average
age of
uh somebody uh of the people buying uh
harley-davidson's is 50 plus
wow from what i understand
the reason they did the three wheelie is
because
many of their potential customers cannot
hold
the bike on its own they need to sit on
something
so it's uh uh the market has changed
they actually hold a lot of the uh of
the money out there
uh so everybody's trying to target the
the aging
uh less the frail the frail is uh it's
harder
it's way way way harder it's a harder
acceptance by the end users
uh we're seeing it right now with a lot
of uh study groups that we're doing uh
to see what would be accepted what would
not be accepted you need to uh get
provide value for the family caregiver
you need to provide value for the older
adult
it needs to be accepted into the home um
you know it's an example of
psychological fear of
many of them are afraid to learn new
tech
because it kind of it puts them in the
position where they feel
that uh they're not in control i see
that
that that losing that lack of control
and not really understanding intuitively
what's happening
sort of i i keep referring back to my my
my grandparents
a lot asked me and i need to ask me even
more to write the instructions for them
on a piece of paper right what are the
step-by-step guides for
opening the zoom or opening the whatsapp
and i was always thinking as a young kid
i would say i kept saying no no it has
to be intuitive it has to be it has to
flow
because tomorrow it might change a
little bit you have to have that
intuition on what to press but
but but i'm i'm starting to understand
more and more that that intuition stems
from just you know
day to day 20 hours a day just playing
with that and yeah and that's not that
and
but that's necessarily something that
can be expected that's exactly the point
the younger generation will play with
okay
my son will sit in front in front of a
new game he will just click everything
and everything and explore and discover
and understand what
was being done for an older adult
there's the fear of pressing a button
they don't understand that anything that
they press to go back it's the fear of
exploring
and therefore they will not explore
right yes
it's not out there and it doesn't
explain exactly what it does
it's not going to be pressed
it's uh it's one of the big challenges
and what we're doing is basically we're
saying two things one
we need to have the option of passing
everything and everything that needs to
be uh dealt with the tech
to the family caregiver meaning i will
drive and move the device
i will bring up the volume or turn down
the volume or the brightness
i'll take care of everything from remote
that's one piece of it and this is the
second is to put enough smarts and ai
on it so we'll be able to do a lot of
those things on its own
right yep talk to me a little bit about
about what you're tangibly doing because
you know you're saying when i read the
mission statement we're creating this
floating device
that is to help you connect with your
with your family that that that sounds
really really cool but tangibly what
what is the product that zp offers
well zip zippy is a video called device
that's basically installed on a helium
balloon
and it's got small drone-like engines
and this thing actually knows how to
move around
and float in the hot in the house
and project the life-size display on the
side of the balloon from the inside
so you can have a video called
conversation with the screen that comes
towards the user not the other way
around if i want to call my dad i just
pick up my mobile phone open the zeppy
app
a video call him and this helium balloon
comes out of a docking station floats
towards my dad
positions itself right in front of him
and we can have a conversation as close
to
me actually being here that's what's
happening symbols ask
so two questions one does it work
and the second one is i have to know
more and how can i buy one
well i started with today's a very
exciting day because we've built
multiple prototypes to verify this
thing can potentially work but today is
the actual
first fully blown prototype that i'm
about to see
the video from my tech cto
genius so it's a very very exciting
uh day uh congratulations i mean
technically
sure you can take like a huge uh
eight footer uh helium balloon and just
pile everything on it then it will work
the challenge is how do you reduce the
weight because on
average about one gram of helium
requires one liter of gas
okay this mobile phone is 180 watts it's
180 liters to pick this up
okay that's a big it's a big balloon so
we need to see that we can reduce the
weights uh
put on everything that needs to that's
required for video call
as in camera speakers microphone display
everything that needs to be done in
order to fly it around like a mini drone
kit
with all the controls and put it piece
it all together put it in a helium build
and uh yes it's feasible it's very
feasible
not trivial but feasible can you go back
and walk me through some of the journey
that you've done
as the entrepreneur do you how do you
converge
to this idea that you want a floating
helium balloon which
to me it sounds you know i'm 24 and i'm
techy and it sounds like sci-fi to me
why why why floating why helium how do
you convert to that
to that strategy uh
well it was actually the other way
around uh because i mean i
you always have to follow the pain um
and uh when i was trying to now identify
well how can i solve and bring to zero
the technical requirements of the older
adult and the helium balloon idea came
up and it was like oh
that is so far-fetched there has to be a
better way
uh what about a display on what about a
robot what about uh
projecting in different walls and uh i
was actually trying to find any and
every other way of not doing it with
helium because
helium has its challenges it's a tricky
right molecule
you need to have like a refill cartridge
on your docking station
it's a it's not a trivial
thing to deal with but
i could not find anything that will be
able to provide the same user experience
and actually bring all the technical
friction to zero i couldn't find it
anything um right
it was the only it was the only way to
bring it was the only way to bring the
screen to the user
it's either that or time presence robots
those kind of ipad on a stick on an
irobot
uh moving on the floor right but those
things are have a lot of challenges with
them and uh
pretty pricey and um
i i wouldn't put one in my home i tested
try
where where is this in five ten years
what do you see
in is this in every household is that
how do you see you know is that
integrating into
the society within five ten years
uh that's a great question well i'm
starting with the older adults because
i think that's not just a nice to have
it's a must-have
and that's why i was saying i'm
following the pain
but i believe that once people see and
feel the user experience that is
exceptionally different i think that
it's gonna
actually go into many many uh homes
and then you can see the additional
layers of services i mean
it's just a dynamic smart home display
so if i'm asking alexa to see a recipe
for something to cook
i'd love to be cooking and have the
display floating next to me
so amazing it can go fur way way way
further
beyond that um but i will say that
i've been in multiple startups and
i'm at my 45ish actually the ideal age
to uh
successfully launch a startup
statistically um
but i found that i i need to feel that
i'm doing something that has
actually uh not just money behind it but
core values that
uh i yes one of the startups that i was
uh looking at before
has also huge potential but i will found
myself sending coupons to people when i
was a
experimenting and i was like is this
what i want to tell my grandkids that i
brought to the world
and i i just don't i jumped it for that
reason i know it's
business-wise uh you can talk about it
but uh you need to wake up in the
morning
it's kind of funny uh in our discussions
with the co-founders of
we talked a lot about uh core values and
integrity and uh
and one of the things is where what do
you want what do you want to do what do
you want to achieve
and i basically i love that well i said
in 10 years
i want to be completely economically
independent
and i want to choose to wake up every
morning and go to the zeppy office
i love that i love that heytan
thank you so much for for spending this
time with me i know how busy you are and
i really appreciate
you spending this time so before we
leave i have to ask you the most
important question which is
the three words that you would use to
describe yourself
uh well people
integrity and passion
i love that anytime thank you very very
much best of luck
and i want to hear from you as soon as i
can buy the very first uh
working prototype because we need it
desperately and i know about a million
other people that do as well
so so thank you for for working so
diligently to make the world better
and stay safe and stay healthy
appreciate it
you